if you're a fan of something and you
find another person who's also a fan of
that thing you're immediately like best
friends and the thing that I am a super
fan of is a movie called Back to the
Future okay Pat like what does that mean
well check this out this is a tweet from
Andy who says I can't even watch Back to
the Future anymore without thinking
about Pat Flynn and SPI here is Chris
who says Back to the Future is playing
right now on ABC I wonder if Pat Flynn
can sense it the big lesson here is a
lot of these little moments and things
about you are what make you unique and
that helps differentiate you and it
might connect with somebody but if
anything it makes you even more unique
it makes you more human